[Music]
astrazeneca's research facility in
sweden
walls here are being torn down to
promote conversation between
scientists that could lead to medical
breakthroughs
it's also a message at the heart of a
stunning new headquarters taking shape
in cambridge
this is bloomberg turn around join me to
see how pascal sorrio
is building transparency and
collaboration
and putting the pep back into
[Music]
astrazeneca
[Music]
when astrazeneca was searching for a new
chief executive in 2011
it was poised to lose 17 billion dollars
in sales
due to expiring patents pascal sorio was
appointed in 2012
his task replenished the drugs pipeline
since his appointment the share price
has doubled
the problem was that we had spent a lot
of time doing rounds and rounds of
course cutting reorganization
and doing share buybacks as opposed to
doing what
what it was we should be doing as an
industry which was
really focusing on science and
developing medicines on day one
sorrio suspended the buybacks soryo
comes more from an operational
and r d background and i think that the
new people that were put in charge were
also the types of people who are more
focused on
on on innovation than than just um
sales and driving the top level so more
about the science absolutely which is
what
pharmaceuticals is about sorrio
increased spending on research and
development
focused on cancer the fastest growing
space in pharmaceuticals
and emboldened scientists to abandon
unsuccessful research
you really have to make sure you choose
projects that will succeed
but it's almost as important to choose
the projects that you should not move
into phase three because if
otherwise you spend a lot of money going
nowhere estracinica
was in a situation where they had been
losing
revenue for years and years and really
through a focus back on science
back on r d they were able to launch a
number of products and the oncology
business unit really started growing and
for the first time in 2018 we saw
astrazeneca
having the energy having the spirit and
showing the growth numbers again and
really delivering on the r d pipeline if
there was a single thing
sorio did to demonstrate his tenure
would be a new dawn
it was his championing of limpaza an
ovarian cancer treatment the previous
management had scrapped
it's now on its way to becoming a
blockbuster the moniker given to a
billion dollar seller
limpazo sparked sorrio's curiosity even
before he joined the company
i talked to keopin leaders and i was
really intrigued because i thought this
drug looks interesting but they're not
doing much with it and in fact they have
they had announced a write-off they had
decided to stop the program
and they had written off the intangible
the goodwill that was associated with
this product project
and i still remember i went to an
european leader
an expert in the field and remember
having this breakfast meeting with him
in the u.s and he looked at me at some
stage and he said look
what you're doing is almost criminal
because these drugs should already be
treating patients
so i arrived with a clear view that it
was one of the medicines i needed to
look at
and in what i found is a research team
that was really convinced this was a
great drug and had been trying to
convince the organization as a whole but
had not been
successful
in 2017 u.s drug maker merck agreed to
pay as much as 8.5 billion
dollars to share in the development of
lympha
which can also be used for pancreatic
and other cancers
the drugs expected to generate 2.5
billion dollars in revenue this year and
next
and along with other key treatments like
tagrisso and
infinzi fuel the gains expected by
analysts
through 2020. he has a nose for a drug
when we showed him the data for
lymphazone when we showed him the data
for degrisso
he realized that these things could be
medicines and he helped us
pull those things through the pipeline
into late stage development and
ultimately
to launch into patients that takes
courage
but it also helps us accelerate and push
things faster
that was tremendous you know so things
that were originally blocked
were now unblocked and moving really
fast through the pipeline
[Music]
astrazeneca was formed in 1999 by the
merger of
sweden's astra and zenica of the uk
it's based in the british university
town of cambridge
where it's surrounded by some of the
most renowned biopharmaceutical
researchers
in the world in our industry it's
fundamental there's nobody who wakes up
one morning
saying okay i've got the solution to
develop
discovering a new product the work we do
requires people to work together you
need the scientists
to understand what the future profile is
going to look like what the potential
competitive angle is and what the
potential way of marketing it would be
and what the physicians would say that's
a very long
list of things to have to deal with when
you're dealing with a program that needs
to take 10 years to come to market
having everyone together and making sure
that they're able to talk to each other
is a key driver menu pangolos showed me
around the new campus
and explained how the building is all
about collaboration
we're really placing ourselves in the
middle in the heart
of one of the best life sciences
clusters in the uk
and actually probably in the world the
idea behind this building is it's meant
to be transparent
porous collaborative inviting to our
partners to people who are interested in
the science that we're doing
so that we really make our science and
our scientists accessible and that's all
part of our cultural transformation
inside this construction there are these
huge laboratories
embedded into the building there's going
to be 19 000 square meters of them
that's three football pictures all the
way along here there's going to be the
desks where the scientists will write up
their experiments
and then of course all the support stuff
i'm told they can't wait to move in
there's a lot more ahead on how
astrazeneca's new buildings are breaking
down barriers
but first fighting off pfizer at the end
of the first day
the bankers must have felt a bit sorry
for me they came and they told me you
know yeah we have to tell you you have
less than 10
chance of remaining independent
[Music]
as a work on boosting astrazeneca's
drugs pipeline started to take off
a fresh threat appeared pfizer
it'd be one of the biggest deals in all
of pharma history
we know that pfizer had made an approach
in january you've got a keen buyer a
very keen buyer
but perhaps not such a keen seller in
this trade in 2014 astra's u.s
rival made four attempts to buy it in
less than six months
the final offer was for 117 billion
dollars
it would have been the biggest
pharmaceuticals takeover
ever
[Music]
it was really an interesting day because
i arrived in london
and opened my phone and my daughter had
sent me a message telling me my wife was
at the hospital with a pulmonary
embolism
so i called her and she was fine but it
was a bit of a bit of a stressful day
and then we arrived at the office and we
started working
the whole day with the lawyers as you
can imagine bankers lawyers and our own
people
and at the end of the first day the
bankers must have felt a bit sorry for
me they came and they told me you know
yeah we have to tell you you have less
than 10
chance of remaining independent
so that was at the end of that day i
thought wow that was
that was an interesting well you didn't
believe them clearly
no actually sometimes you know when
people tell me a project has a low
probability of success and i believe in
it
i tell them you know 20 is not bad
actually because i only had 10 of uh
chance of remaining independent
as fisher continued to chase to create
the world's largest drug maker by sales
lawmakers in britain sweden and the us
grew
increasingly critical the most important
intervention we can make
is to back british jobs british science
british r d
british medicines and british technology
and that is why
i asked the cabinet secretary and my
ministers to engage with both
companies right from the start of this
process
astrazeneca rejected the deal
disappointing many investors
this price doesn't reflect the newest
razer car
in the last 18 months we've made
enormous progress we're building our
pipeline
and we believe this pipeline is going to
deliver our value
for patients of course but also for our
shareholders you had the board on side
but you
investors many investors saying no it
was the wrong thing to do
but i also understand that you managed
to use this situation
as a way of galvanizing the staff what
happened there
yeah i think it it was of course a
stressful time for a stressful
yes for everybody in the company but it
was also a great time
in retrospect because it was a time when
we had this burning platform
of showing that we could actually
deliver value
not only to patients but also to our
shareholders we're just focusing on what
we were doing
and it really galvanized everybody to
actually
uh you know do their best and that meant
showcasing that astrazeneca's future was
bright
sorrier projected a 75 increase in
annual revenue
by 2023 and announced the company had
15 drugs nearly ready to go almost
double
from the year before he promised
investors their shares would rise beyond
the 55 pound offer price
it took four years to get there our job
is to turn science into medicine and
ultimately get those medicines to
patients
you looked at our success rates from
2005 to 2010
our success rate from drugs entering
clinical development first in human
experiments to launch
were around four percent today in the
most recent assessment we've done which
was looking at 2012
2016 our success rate has now gone up to
20
we were very good at focusing on large
numbers of projects
but that actually had a relatively low
probability of being medicines
today we very much focus on the quality
we actually cut almost half of the
projects in the pipeline
and even without cut we still improved
our success rate significantly so that
was
quality not quantities hugely hugely
important
it's important to remain nimble and and
fast-paced but
in order to do that and make decisions
you yourself as a leader have to have
a fair quantity of self-belief where
does that come from
well it's actually more than
self-benefits about
belief in the people you have around you
believe in
the advice you get believe in in the
culture you've created
and it's really about digging in the
data
understanding what physicians think
experts think and
you know aggregating all of this and
analyzing it and at the end of the day
it's about the belief of
that you have to take risks and then and
then at some point you have to accept
you may be
you may fail what is it that you bring
to the organization
that allows that um that that
communication to come out
and and for these drugs to be recognized
when it wasn't before
one of the most important time points is
when you
you are in phase one phase two and you
have to decide whether drugs should be
developed in phase
three and here you really have to look
at it from all angles
and really understand where it could
help patients and how it could be used
in clinical practice
and the way you do this is really by
bringing people together
and and and really you know
brainstorming and debating and
discussing the data and the various
opinions
but also beyond that i think you need to
create the right
kind of culture one of the issues we had
was
you know we had exp experience a few
setbacks
in development we had three products
that failed in next stage development
in 2007-8 or something like that and
that happens
all the companies have experienced that
but at the time the management the
company
decided okay well we're not going to
fail again and so
you know when you tell people we're not
going to fail you never fail in phase 3
because you never move anything in fact
3.
you got to really create an environment
where people
feel comfortable taking some educated
risks
so it really is about sharing knowledge
sharing data debating
and being willing to take educated risks
[Music]
we have entered into an agreement of
global joint development and
commercialization
with astrazeneca sorrio's most
significant educated risk so far
was a 6.9 billion dollar deal in march
with japan's taiichi sankyo to develop a
breast cancer treatment that could
even replace chemotherapy potentially
reshaping the future of cancer care the
potential is very large
and we see it as a mega blockbuster
astrazeneca was obliged to partly fund
it
with a 3.5 billion share sale
highlighting the company's scarce cash
resources
they needed to raise money from the
market and they raised a little bit more
because they have some debt repayments
coming up
that i think highlighted the cash flow
needs
of course they could have gone and
probably given up some other rating
and raised debt again but that would
have been expensive
people would say equity is expensive but
at the end of the day
this was a much faster way of getting
what they needed and they did it
but that's if there's a focus on cash
flow the daiichi deal
why is that a a key deal for astrazeneca
i think people today don't really
understand fully the potential of this
medicine it can transform breast cancer
treatment
and i personally believe it can be a
very big product and i don't think
people
have totally realized how big it can be
coming up we go to sweden where
astrazeneca has thrown away the keys
and invited outside businesses to
install themselves
right next to its scientists
the emphasis on bringing people together
is a key plank of sorrio's turnaround
the investment into buildings like this
in cambridge
and these in sweden is all about getting
people to come together
and share ideas
[Music]
the company was operating in silos and
and actually not necessarily believing
in each other so you had a commercial
function and then you had the rnd
function
and and and there was not a lot of
belief
uh say in commercial that rnd was
delivering
and in r d we had also fragmented teams
we had the medium team we had you know
very diff
many different teams not working really
[Music]
together
at the gothenburg site there is a huge
model that shows how existing
and new buildings are going to work
together
most of the world's brilliant minds do
not work for astrazeneca
we have 64 000 fantastic employees
but most great ideas are conceived
somewhere else and if we are going to
take part of that we are going to
have to work completely different with
the external world
joachim reichel is one of those charged
with making the changes
all right this is clearly one of the
modern
new facilities for research and
development why does this work
more productively for astrazeneca as you
can see it's a much more open
environment
we have torn down the walls and we have
scientists from different disciplines
working in this environment which makes
it easier for collaboration
why does it make it easier are they
working on the same disciplines or are
they they're working on different
diseases we have scientists that are
researching heart disease
kidney disease and respiratory disease
and the interesting thing is
that those diseases have some
commonalities which now
we can actually understand better by
having those scientists working together
in the same space and so before
all of these people would have been
working separately on their own
disciplines
they would have been working separate
labs absolutely
another innovation is the bioventure hub
where companies are invited to establish
themselves
inside the campus and given the same
access as the rest of the staff
what it means in practice as i see it is
that talented people
with new technologies and new ideas will
get
inside assassinica build their companies
build their develop their science and
they will do that together with
assassina formerly and formally
this is a completely different company
so as an example
we today have our bioventure hub here at
the company it's
34 external companies same pass card as
i have
access to our full site we share
knowledge
about 18 years ago when i joined
astrasenko we almost pulled down the
curtains before open a drawer
that that's a major major change that
with anger
katharina aggerborg the chief executive
of astrazeneca sweden
says the coffee lab at the gothenburg
campus is but one example of how the
dynamic is changing inside the company
i think the biggest thing is the
cultural change and in how we operate
in terms of opening up working a lot
more with the
smaller companies academia and you know
just around the world collaborating more
externally
not assuming we have the best people
every day inside but rather
opening up is one big thing
i also think actually the cultural thing
sometimes we forget that it's
he has been driving a very very
values-driven way of working
i think if you walk around here or
anywhere in astrazeneca
everyone would know our five values and
it actually
really means something to people so you
know we put patients first
we follow the science we're
entrepreneurial
we play to win and we do the right thing
sorrio continues to make changes to gain
an edge
in january he reorganized r d into two
divisions one to focus on cancer
the fastest growing and most lucrative
part of the industry
and the other to oversee the rest it was
necessary because the structure we had
in place served us very well for about
five years or so
five years ago we didn't have much in
our pipeline we had to create this uh
early units there were kind of a biotech
units coming up with new products
but as we were becoming more successful
with the full pipeline
the structure was playing against us a
little bit we were becoming a bit too
bureaucratic and to focus on governance
and our oncology
pipeline in particular has grown
tremendously
and oncology is a little bit different
from the rest of pharmaceuticals
so i decided that the reorganization was
necessary so we could move
very quickly from research to early
development to late development in
oncology
bring people together from research to
development to commercial
in oncology but also in
biopharmaceuticals and when it comes to
building new markets
astrazeneca like many is looking to
china
and its increasingly affluent patients
when did you first begin to see
china as a key market
almost immediately because you know the
as i started i really had to look for
areas where we could grow you know i had
to look for the strengths of the company
and and number one where we could
rebuild the pipeline how we could
rebuild the pipeline but also
looking at this massive patent expiry
that we were facing
where could i find growth and china was
one of those
and in fact the pipeline of the
portfolio of products we had and still
have
really addresses the needs of patients
in china so immediately i thought you
know we have to invest in china and keep
going
since becoming astrazeneca's ceo sorio
has
refocused the company on science he's
reconfigured buildings to
open them to outside minds and ideas and
he's replenished
the company's pipeline 2012 astra seneca
was a completely different
company we had great sales
great profit and virtually no pipeline
whatsoever
this is the time that pascal's rio came
into the company
and that the company changed leadership
so
if we fast forward from that time about
five or six years from
almost no pipeline whatsoever
some analysts claimed that we had the
best pipeline in the industry
the questions remain about the dearth of
cash flow
highlighted by the daiichi deal the
issue for
astra is that there's only so much cash
and as we know that is one of the key
questions around the company
let's go more into that though so why is
that a question well
pharmaceutical companies are
historically
great cash generators there's two
reasons people have historically
invested in pharmaceutical companies
one is the the fact that they're driven
by demographics and they are
a defensive sector normally and the
other one is that
they throw off tons of cash so where the
cash flow becomes a bit thinner
that becomes a question and of course
there's
not much you can do when three say
roughly five billion dollar products at
the same time are going off patent
and products at the end of their lives
are very profitable because they don't
need much detailing
how do you you know how do you replace
that that's that's a pretty difficult
thing to do
that said fazeley says astrazeneca's
latest results
did indicate that cash flow is going to
improve on the back of growth and high
margin products
as far as sorry is concerned it's not
his biggest worry
witness a decision announced in june to
invest 630 million
over the next five years in the south
korean health care sector
or a 220 million commitment to vietnam's
health sector
unveiled in may the bigger risk for us
is to become complacent
actually you know it's interesting we
didn't have anything
we then were potentially acquired and
there was an enormous
burning platform for all of us to do our
best and
work hard and move fast and as you
become successful you can become
slower and more complacent so that's the
one thing really
we i don't want to see happen
[Music]
you